[Music]  yesterday the coastguard offloaded 6000  pounds of cocaine that they found  floating off the coast of Miami yeah now  even though the cocaine was removed from  the ocean I think it's still having a  residual effect check out this footage  from the Atlantic Wildlife Foundation  hey you wanna party you want a party do  a bump come on do it with me come on you  wanna party don't be a dick I mean you  could argue that the smiths title alpha  was their best that some people swear by  meat is murder and I know that everyone  agrees that the queen is dead like  they're sorry pepper but that doesn't  even gloss over Strangeways here we come  he's a cop  he's a cop stay cool everybody never  again never again good guy  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]